Hello everyone.
I'm Ora Lenner. I'm the CEO of Bright Data,
and today we're gonna talk about
something that sounds trivial but actually it's
not. It's intelligent models
versus knowledgeable models
and what does that mean?
So it's been exactly 3 years
since the launch of ChaGPT 3
and that magical moment.
To me, the magic continues. I
keep working with these tools
like everyone
else here.
And
we're experiencing this same magical moment
only almost on an hourly
basis when we're using the tools, right? It's
super intelligent models. They
know everything about the world.
They actually answer very
complicated
questions. They're winning gold
medal, uh, in, in the meth Olympics,
so their intelligence level is extremely
high. By definition, the models that
we're using today are the smartest
the world has ever seen,
and their next version that might come
up tomorrow or the next
foundational model builder that we might
launch their model in a week
by definition will be smarter,
so the intelligent level keeps on
growing and expanding and it's just
magical. However,
all of you know the feeling that you're using
this intelligent model.
And at the same time it can
be, I don't have any other
better word to use,
extremely stupid
on various things that you actually
want to achieve on
just a daily routine, you
know, buying something on
just asking something simple
that every 5 years old can answer,
but if it's lacking the knowledge,
intelligence is not enough, and this is
what we're going to talk about today.
And we're going to look at it from the
data perspective.
Pausing this thought for a second, I want
to introduce briefly Bright Data
and kind of show you the reason
that
or, or, or the, the, the
ability of Bright data to look into
this um
intelligence versus knowledge
and model ecosystem and our unique
position
into, into the AI
industry. So
Bright Data serves 20,000 customers
today that are
obsessed about getting the data they
need that they need from the public web
in order to do various things
including AI.
So this includes most of the large
language models and foundational models
and pretty much every other AI company
that builds on top of the, of
these models
and they, when they need data for training
or even data for real-time.
They come to us. It also means
that the largest e-commerce platforms
that needs to understand what's going on in the world
and be competitive when you're coming
to their website to buy something are
also using our infrastructure to get
web data.
Same goes for financial services.
Think of the largest American banks that
need to get smart
investment decisions.
They need data for that.
Cybersecurity as well,
to find a threat
in this
huge ecosystem of the World
Wide Web, you actually need to collect a
lot of data.
And many other industries
and vertical news cases that all
need web data.
This creates massive scale.
We see roughly 50 billion
web pages a day. Our customers
are using the Bright Data platform to
collect data
from this huge amount
of internet on a daily basis.
That's 3/3 times
more of all of the Google search queries
globally, worldwide, every single
day. So the scale is massive.
And it's not an easy thing to do.
We invest a lot in research
and development and considered to be one
of the leading companies in the world
when it comes to different technologies
around web data collection, web scraping.
We also keep a very large portion
of the internet that we're seeing,
and we are increasing
our web archive that just passed 450
billion webpages and growing
very, very fast.
And to do all of that we have
the largest known
um pool of bots that
are actually using and browsing
the web
every second of the day
to collect this information.
So when we are talking about
AI in the form of or in
the sense of data,
we know what we're talking about because we are
the largest vendor for the AI industry
when it comes to data.
Now
When you want to build an intelligent model.
You need 3 major ingredients and that's
kind of obvious today for everyone, right?
One is very smart people to ride the
sophisticated algorithm of the large language
model. Then you also need a lot
of compute to train the model and
obviously you need a lot of data to feed
those massive clusters of GPUs
that needs to
train the model.
Now, the trends that we're seeing as
the largest web data provider for this
industry. are as follows we see
that on the
Algorithm side,
the open source and open weight
models are already in par
with the closed source closed weights models,
right? So
you will get almost identical
performance on almost all of the evil
tests out there when you compare
open source open weights to closed source close
weights. In addition to that,
we see that training is becoming
cheaper. It's not just
the cost of acquiring the compute
and the GPUs, it's also what
you can do today
with previous generations of GPUs,
but also the cost of energy
and the cost of cooling, which is essential
to training large language models,
is decreasing and actually it's, it's
going down pretty fast.
So if the starting point to
train new models is
actually easier than ever before, I'm
not saying it's easy, but it's easier
than ever before.
Then what we're seeing as a data company
is that the data becomes the major mode.
Because if you can all get the same compute
and use the same open source, open
weight models, then the data
matters the most.
Now, with that background of our scale
and what we're seeing and the fact that we're servicing
the vast majority of the foundational model
builders,
let's get back
to the subject we started with, intelligent
versus knowledgeable.
LLMs.
Now, an, an, an analogy
I like to use is
physics.
Can a theoretical physics prove a new
phenomenon?
Just think about the brain of
a physic.
The answer is no. What they can
do is describe the new phenomenon.
They have a theory. They can describe it.
They can propose and develop theories
and models
in order to prove or disprove
this theory.
But it stops there, so they
can be very, very smart, very
intelligent,
but it stops there.
What they can do afterwards is
work with their colleague that experimental
physics.
To run an experiment
in order to provide evidence and
prove or disprove
this new theory or this new phenomenon.
LLMs today works the same.
So using the same analogy, I'll ask
a different question.
Can an LLM purchase the right product
for you today?
And we'll also talk about the future.
But
today it's very,
it is very intelligent and
sophisticated
model that you can use,
the answer is no, it can't actually
do that
simple task of, let's say,
buying milk that you
can pour into the
bowl of cereals that you want to eat
tomorrow morning in your breakfast.
It just can't do that.
So
today the models are more like the theoretical.
Physics
And they're still lacking that knowledge
to actually do that experiment
in physics, but in the real world
to buy that carton of milk
so you can
eat your cereals.
So, if it doesn't have
the real-time price, just one example
of a crucial piece of
information so that for you to use the model
to make it both efficient, smart,
and useful for you,
then it's not there yet.
And as the Internet, that
World Wide Web,
last 30 years of information that
was, you know,
built by the largest tech companies
out there and all of the data that is generated
is becoming that infrastructure layer
for the new Internet, these chatbots
that we're all using,
we see
two major trends that are taking
shape in 2025
and.
Something big is gonna happen in 2026,
which is only a few weeks away, and we're gonna
cover that as well, but what we're seeing
is that everyone is consuming
as much data as they can
to build the most intelligent
models
and if this graph represents the
usage growth.
Of data for training, you can see
that it is growing and it's not
gonna stop growing.
However, it is growing in a linear
manner. And
you already have these very sophisticated intelligent
models,
right? So let's use this
example of milk again. These models
can tell you
everything about the ingredients of the milk.
They can tell you
about the class action lawsuit that
the milk company
got 10 years ago and what
was the outcome.
They're perfect for that,
but what we're seeing now
is an absolute explosion
and an exponential growth
when it comes to real-time data
to add also the knowledge layer
on top of the intelligent layer to
also tell you what is the
price of the milk, not just
everything about the ingredients of the milk.
This is not a vision, this is what we're seeing
from our perspective as the largest
data vendor for this industry.
And OK.
Got back and we're seeing that
not just in milk obviously
everywhere just think about the world around you
think about what you're doing every
day. You wanna
know everything about the Las Vegas
sphere but also you wanna go to a
show so the intelligent
layer of the model will tell you
everything about the construction of the sphere
and how much it cost and who was the
construction company.
And everything you wanna know about it, but
to buy a ticket
to tonight's show in the sphere,
you can't do that
unless you're adding the knowledge layer
and giving it to the uh uh allowing
the LLM to access that layer, and this
is the current trend that is starting
to take shape
again, it's not there yet, but this is the trends
that we're seeing adding knowledge
on top of intelligence.
Now I took
um a very um popular
evil test that is working
specifically or testing specifically
reasoning and knowledge,
exactly what we're here to talk about.
And you can see all of the models
performing one way or another.
And for this event
I was focusing on the Chat GPT
open source 120 billion
tokens
that everyone can use and test
as an open source tool and what
we're gonna see now.
is an example for using
only that intelligent
and again very intelligent.
In this case, the open source of
GPT.
But lacking that knowledge layer,
and that will be on the left hand side.
On the right hand side, we will see
the same model exactly using
that knowledge layer.
In this case, the bright data MCP.
So giving
that open source LLM
access to real-time information from
the web.
Let's take a look.
It's a bit hard to see from far, so
I'll explain.
We are asking about salaries
from Glassdoor in different companies.
We just wanna know that because we wanna recruit
on the left hand side without access
to web to, to real-time web
data.
The model kind of says in, in, in a
very apologetic way,
sorry, I can't get this information.
So actually completely useless. I just
got the most sophisticated model out there.
That is completely useless for a daily task
that I want to perform.
On the right hand side with the bright data MCP,
it actually got you a complete table
with all of the information you wanted to get
everything, the salaries, per position
in different companies.
As a human, you can do it in 5
minutes,
but taking that super smart
model that can win a gold medal in
math Olympics,
you just can't do that without that
knowledge layer that gives you access
to the web.
We're seeing by working
with these companies that in 2026,
the the knowledge layer
and the
intelligent layer are gonna merge.
This is
something huge for us, for
humanity I would even say,
because this is where it is actually going
to automate
everything that we're doing.
It's not gonna happen in one day.
But you're starting seeing that in e-commerce,
in travel, when you're not
just using these models to plan
your, your trip or you're not using
these models just to
um ask a question about the product.
We're starting to see and sense the ability
of actually getting the relevant
real-time information like the availability
of the product,
the price of the product, the shipping time
of the product to your
location. Or the price of that
flight or hotel room.
And
again, from our perspective, from
the data perspective, we're seeing that in 2026,
this is going to unlock
a huge
Huge opportunity for
everyone who's working on
AI with AI and just for
everyone in the world who is using these tools
because when you combine knowledge with intelligence,
It's really unlocking
everything that we're doing as humans. It, it can
and will replace a lot of the tasks that we're
doing on a daily basis
that you don't really need to put in effort
anymore. You can use your time doing
other things.
I'll finish by
Inviting everyone again to our very
Cool and interesting and unique
event tonight in the Battlebot
Arena.
Um,
you can visit our booth right after this call
and the talk and take, uh,
all the details and we'll see you there in a very
exciting, um,
bot event. Thank you for joining.